President George HW Bush passes away
Russia gate continues to unfold in Paris
bursts into flame we'll get into all of
it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show oh man so much to get to a
lot happened over the weekend in Russia
gate and of course President George HW
Bush passes away and this leads the
media to discover that honor did exist
in the Republican Party at once have it
no longer does well get into all of that
in just one second first let's talk
about how you're going to send your mail
this Christmas or this Hanukkah with the
holidays this means that you're going to
be spending a lot on postage and that
also means they're gonna be slepping a
lot of boxes down to the post office
well why do all of that when you can get
all of the great services of the post
office directly from your desk over at
stamps comm stamps.com brings all those
great services right to your desktop by
and prints official US postage for any
letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer and
then the mail carrier just picks it up
no trips to the post office required it
could not be easier print postage any
day any time because stamps comments
always open you're not restricted to
post office hours
they not only save you time they save
you money stamps comm helps you print
the right amounts of postage every time
so you're not overpaying and with stamps
calm you'll also get discounts that you
can't get even at the post office
stamps calm is a great gift to give
yourself this holiday season I use
stamps calm here at the Daily wire
offices I use it at home as well and
right now you can enjoy that stamps comm
service with a special offer special
offer four week trial plus postage in a
digital scale without long term
commitments go to stamps calm click on
the microphone at the top of the home
page type in promo code Shapiro Pettis
stamps calm enter promo code Shapiro go
check it out right now stamps calm promo
code Shapiro for that special deal all
right over the weekend President George
HW Bush Bush 41 as they call him passed
away at the age of 94 HW was in fact an
American hero his entire life was
dedicated to American public service
according to the Associated Press the
public viewing for President George HW
Bush will begin for date will kick off
for days of events that will include a
state funeral at Washington's National
Cathedral on Wednesday and a private
service at President Bush's longtime
Church in Houston on Thursday his body
is supposed to arrive in Washington
today for public viewing in the Capitol
Rotunda which is a rare honor that is
only bestowed
on a few former Secretary of State Colin
Powell calls him a perfect American for
how he served his country in so many
capacities he died at his Houston home
at age 94 over the weekend his crowning
achievement as president was assembling
the International military coalition
according to The Associated Press that
liberated Kuwait from invading Iraq in
1991 in a war that lasted just 100 hours
at the time he was ripped up and down
for not invading Iraq directly and going
after Saddam Hussein he said that was
beyond the mission and obviously later
events it seemed to have justified that
to at least a certain extent he was a
humble hero of World War two he was just
20 when he survived being shot down
during a bombing run over Japan he
enlisted in the Navy on his 18th
birthday he in fact foregut for went his
actual Yale scholarship to instead go
into the Navy he was shot down while he
was in the Navy in fact they have tape
that was played during the 1992 and 1988
presidential runs that showed him
actually being dragged out of the ocean
by fellow members of the Navy he's the
youngest Navy pilot in America at the
time he was dragged out of the water
here some of that footage here's what it
looked like ii 1944 USS finback rescued
lieutenant junior grade George HW Bush
who was shot down while attacking chichi
Jima during this time Bush was attached
to USS San Jacinto while serving with
torpedo squadron 51 Bush later becomes
the 41st president of the United States
yeah.well is interesting because Michael
Dukakis his campaign manager said in
1988 at the moment that they saw that
footage on television they knew that
Michael Dukakis was never going to be
president because again that the footage
is pretty heroic shortly after he left
the service he married his 19 year old
sweetheart Barbara Pierson a union that
lasted until her death earlier this year
he turned his attention to politics in
the 1960s he was elected to his first
two terms in Congress in 1967 he then
went on to serve as ambassador to the UN
and China head of the CIA chairman of
the Republican National Committee before
he was elected to two terms as vice
president of the United States and then
of course he served one term as
president of the United States before
being defeated by Bill Clinton in 1992
in a hotly contested election that saw
Ross Perot when 19% of the popular vote
now what's been fascinating to watch in
the aftermath of George HW Bush's death
is the sort of sepia glow that has been
calf
on George HW Bush by all of his
political opponents we saw the same
thing happened to Senator John McCain
after McCain's death earlier this year
suddenly all the people who spent their
careers talking about how John McCain
was a war monger we're saying that he
was in he was just the great example of
American statesmanship we saw the same
thing with George HW Bush immediately
after his death this weekend suddenly he
was a great American Statesman
suddenly he was wonderful man suddenly
he was a just an example of the kind of
person who could unify the country we
saw since Mitt Romney after he lost in
2012 he gave a concession speech and
suddenly the left's like wow look at
that that guy's great where was that guy
during the campaign and many of us were
saying well he was there the whole time
you were just forcibly ignoring the fact
that Mitt Romney was a good man so he
could slander him an attack him so he
wouldn't become president it was the
same thing with George HW Bush who in
1991 was ripped by the left as a
warmonger who's ripped by the left as an
incompetent who's ripped by the left as
cold aloof not in touch with the
American people a racist in 1988 for
running the Willie Horton ad right he
didn't even run it was a super PAC kind
of quasi associated with his campaign
that ran the Willie Horton ad but who
was George HW Bush's man I think that
the best clip that shows who he was a
man this comes circus in 1979 so in 1979
George HW Bush was coming off running
the CIA he had he ran for president in
1979 and he ran against Ronald Reagan he
ran against Bob Dole all these people
would go on to become presidential
candidates in their own right and he was
asked specifically about whether he was
tough enough to be President which is an
amazing question to ask a guy who
volunteered for the Navy and then was
shot down going on to complete his
mission by the way here is George HW
Bush being asked about his toughness
circa 1979 toughness with just attacking
some individual I don't attack I equate
toughness with moral fiber with
character with principled with
demonstrated leadership in tough jobs
where you emerge not bullying somebody
but with the respect of the people you
lid that's toughness that's fiber that's
character I've got it and if I happen to
be decent in the process that should not
be a liability okay and then he was
asked specifically about his political
opponents in that clip he's asked about
Bob Dole he says is Bob Dole too aloof
and he says no he says his Ronald Reagan
No and then he specifically refuses to
attack his other political opponents on
the stage and that was fairly common for
George HW Bush now look as a very
conservative Republican was I the
biggest fan of George HW Bush's
presidency me to be frank I wasn't there
for most of it at least into politics I
was four years old when he took office
and I was able left so but but in
retrospect so I look back at his
presidency and say that was a shining
example of what an American presidency
should be and I have severe policy
differences with George HW Bush George
HW Bush did not keep his promise not to
raise taxes George HW Bush sold AWACS to
the Saudis George HW Bush you know on
foreign policy I am NOT with the common
consensus that in 1991 he shouldn't have
gone into post and I'm Hussein at the
time it would have certainly saved
America a lot of trouble in the long run
if he had done so but with all of that
said was George HW Bush a deeply
honorable human being there's no
question he was a deeply honorable human
being he was a good man this is a good
man with a good wife and a good family
and we're seeing the same thing happened
to George W Bush in the aftermath of his
presidency suddenly a guy they were
attacking as Bush Hitler is now being
recast as a man who wanted Americans to
get along us a totem of a kinder gentler
era and this is exactly what you're
seeing folks on the Left say about
George HW Bush Juan Williams says you
know the the transformation of HW Bush
into the party of Donald Trump
demonstrates that there was a kinder
gentler time America way I think of it
Chris is sort of optimism versus
pessimism morning in America a kinder
gentler America versus American carnage
as a message coming from the leader to
the American people so when I think of
President Bush I think of someone who
crossed the aisle you know I was really
taken by what Karl just said about his
best friend being a Democrat and while
he's served those two terms in Congress
and of course he followed reagan's
pronouncement 11th commandment speak no
evil of another republican so I'm not a
huge fan of George HW Bush's
bipartisanship while he was in office
and while his presidents of the United
States but I'm getting rather tired of a
bunch of folks on the Left who would
have ripped George HW Bush while he was
president now turning around say it was
a kinder gentler America no it wasn't
it's just that you like
Republican once that Republican is no
longer in office and you specifically
used those Republicans as clubs to hit
the current Republican let's be let's be
frank about this when when Senator John
McCain died there all these tributes
that came in from the left people who
had called him a war monger and said
that John McCain was was the guy who was
joking about bom bom bom bom bom Moran
right there they were doing this whole
routine while he was alive he dies and
suddenly the man is just a semblance of
a time gone by and now it's the same
thing with George HW Bush are you
sensing a are you sensing a sort of
pattern here a pattern from the left
that because Donald Trump is president
every Republican who is not Donald Trump
is now seen in a kinder gentler light
the fact is the reason the press are
paying the sort of attention to George
HW Bush is not because they've suddenly
been struck by the honor and decency of
the man George HW Bush it is also
because of the fact that so many folks
on the Left want to see George HW Bush
contrasted unkindly with Donald Trump
and I'm not gonna pretend that in terms
of character Donald Trump and George HW
Bush are on the same plane I don't think
they're on the same plane I don't think
that George HW Bush is the kind of man
that Donald Trump is in order I think
Donald Trump is the same kind of man as
George W Bush they're very different
human beings George HW Bush was a man
who volunteered to serve in the military
Donald Trump is a man who did not and
not only that you know used a number of
excuses to get out of the draft George
HW Bush is the kind of man who devoted
his life to public service Donald Trump
is the kind of man who has devoted his
life to you know to to business and and
fame none of that is specifically a rip
on Donald Trump but the contrast is not
kind to Donald Trump between George HW
Bush and Trump which is of course
exactly why the press is making that
contrast in the first place don't trust
the press when suddenly they start
telling you that a Republican is
wonderful because the only Republicans
that president that their left thinks
are wonderful are ones who are out of
office or dead I mean that's the basic
rule of thumb here and every so often
every so often they sort of let the
masks slip franklin foer let the masks
slip over at the atlantic when he
suggested that George HW Bush was not a
man of courage right he actually did not
here's how he concluded his eulogy of
George HW Bush and this is a rare
example of honesty from the left on how
they actually felt about George HW Bush
while he was alive here's a
for who's disgusting said over at the
Atlantic obituaries present George HW
Bush as the last of the Republican
moderates in reality here's an
archetypal representative of the modern
party a man whose sense of duty failed
him when it came to resisting the rise
of racially revanchist libertarian
forces he embodied an establishment that
wrote a very nice thank-you notes but
good manners are hardly the same his
moral courage prudence is sometimes
called hard-hearted those who are
mourning the passing of the old
establishment should mourn as many
failures to that's how the left really
felt about George HW Bush and don't let
them put on the masks of morning in
order to pretend that George HW Bush was
something different for them than Donald
Trump you and I we can see the
differences between George HW Bush and
Donald Trump which were many and myriad
some in favor of Bush in terms of
character some not in favor of Bush
maybe in terms of policy but for the
left the only reason that they are now
donning the mask of mourning when it
comes to George HW Bush is that they can
attempt to proclaim that Donald Trump is
significantly worse by any sort of
comparison Hey in just a second I want
to talk to you about George HW Bush's
final words and whatever whenever a man
of honor dies it's it's a loss obviously
to the country and the stories of his
death are pretty moving and talk about
that in just one second but first let's
talk about what's going to hit you when
you unwrap a brand new phone this
Christmas okay that brand new monthly
bill that's gonna come along with it
it's not going to be great big wireless
providers can seriously suck the joy out
of the holiday so this year
don't just upgrade your phone upgrade
your wireless provider and switch to MIT
mobile for a limited time mint Mobile is
offering the best holiday deal in
wireless that you have ever seen in
three months of service for only 20
bucks which is unbelievable three months
of cell service for just $20 min mobiles
holiday deal is only here for a limited
time
20 bucks total it gets you three months
of wireless service with five gigs of 4G
LTE data each month plus unlimited talk
and text not gonna get a better deal
than this use your own phone along with
any mint mobile plan you can keep your
old phone number along with all your
existing contacts mid mobile runs on the
nation's fastest most advanced LTE
network if you're not 100% satisfied
mint mobile has you covered but there's
seven day money-back guarantee so you
really have nothing to lose ditch that
old wireless bill start saving with mint
mobile no reason to rack up charges this
Christmas or Hanukkah instead why don't
you go get mint mobile you can get that
great new phone and also you don't have
to pay through the nose take advantage
of that mint mobile holiday deal before
it's gone at three months of wireless
for 20 bucks get the plan shipped to
your door for free by going to MIT
mobile comm slash Ben that is Mint
mobile.com slash Pentagon three months
of service for just 20 bucks at mint
mobile comm slash Ben M int mobile comm
slash man go check it out right now all
right so the stories of President Bush's
death are really moving I mean this is a
man with it's hard to imagine a better
American family a son who was a governor
another son who's president of the
United States and governor of Texas a
family and third-generation of politics
pretty amazing stuff again as I
emphasized I think that it is fair for
people on the right to talk about the
the goodness of George HW Bush if they
didn't spend their careers attacking him
as a bad man people like franklin foer
over at the atlantic i think are more
reflective of what left really thinks
about george HW bush again franklin foer
ripping into george HW bush saying he
did have new moral courage when's the
last time franklin foer signed up for
the military in the middle of World War
two it's just it's just amazing I just
quit final mode from Franklin floor
before we get to the last words of
George HW Bush Franklin for writes one
of the great counterfactuals of American
history is pondering what would have
happened if George Bush had exerted
greater control over the destiny of the
Republican Party what if the moderate
Republicans in the late 50s and early
60s had aggressively owned the civil
rights agenda and rendered the cause of
racial justice of bipartisan concern by
the way they did more Republicans voted
for the Civil Rights Act as a percentage
than Democrats did if the old money
Republicans could have mustered that
leadership stood firm against the flow
of segregationists into their club it
might have precluded the invention of
Richard Nixon's Southern Strategy and
the generations of racialized politics
that followed does anyone really believe
by the way that this was all about
George HW Bush failing to stem the flow
of racist into the Republican Party but
this is how the left really thinks about
all of these folks right this is how the
left really thinks about all these but
in any case James Baker who was George
HW Bush's lifelong friend and Secretary
of State he was on CNN which actually
their coverage of HW was excellent and
James Baker was talking to Jake Tapper
about HW s final words they got the kids
on the phone and each one of them spoke
to him and he spoke back or mumbled back
anyway and then they got 43 on the phone
and 43 said I love you dad and
and I just want to and I'll see you in
heaven and 41 said I love you too and
those are the last words that he ever
spoke I mean that's that's pretty
amazing you can't ask for more from from
a life than that
it's it is amazing when somebody gets to
live the life that they sought to live
even when they pass away it's obviously
in a credit to them as a human being if
you can live your entire life and die
saying I love you your children it
doesn't get a lot better than that
especially when your child happens to
also have been president of the United
States pretty amazing stuff
all right meanwhile Russia Gate
continues and the and the left is is
fully invested in Russia gate that this
is what's going to take down President
Trump but you can see the excitement
from so many folks on the left now again
the evidence is not in that President
Trump actively colluded with the
Russians to steal the 2016 election or
anything like that and so the left is
now shifting their argument they've said
that our argument several times the
first was that the that the Trump
campaign had been compromised by the
Russians the Russians basically had
compromised you remember on President
Trump and they're going to use that
compromise in order to affect his role
in office that has not been proved there
is no evidence of that
then they shifted the arguments to
President Trump was coordinating with
the Russians to hack Hillary Clinton's
emails and the DNC and then to
militarize the release of those emails
to win the election again that has not
been proved either then it turned into
President Trump
maybe received some of those emails and
they point out connections between Roger
stone and other members of the sort of
Trump coterie and that has not been
proved yet either so now let's move to
president Trump had business
relationships in Russia at the same time
that he was running for president and
that's true but that's also not
criminals even Andrea Mitchell over at
MSNBC was recognizing she says you know
President Trump is saying it's not
illegal for him to do business in Russia
that of course is exactly true
presidents correct it's not illegal for
an international businessman to be doing
the business the conflicts of interest
are profound it's not illegal yet and
she is right about this Jake Tapper made
this point last week also that's not
stopping some Democrats from now trying
to say that because Trump had business
contacts in Russia that means that he
was in some way compromised so Adam
Schiff the representative from
California who has his pup tent set up
outside the media headquarters I mean
again
it's amazing he's actually brought in an
electric generator he's dug a pit for
the outhouse and the guys start he's
starting to hook up the plumbing but he
hasn't actually connected it to mainline
yet right outside these headquarters he
was on ABC's this week talking again
about michael cohen and russia gate and
president trump what Michael Cohen was
saying and others were saying about when
this business deal ended was not true
and what's more the Russians knew it
wasn't true that at the same time that
Donald Trump was the presumptive nominee
of the GOP and arguing in favor of doing
away with sanctions he was working on a
deal that would require doing away with
sanctions for him to make money in
Russia that is a real problem it means
that the compromise is far broader than
we thought there we go so it's
compromise we're back to the original
theory except again the theory is not
supported by any evidence Donna Brazile
former head of the DNC she was saying
the same thing and Michael Cohen
pleading guilty to lying to the FBI that
this is in fact a smoking gun it is not
a smoking gun of anything other than
Michael Cohen lied to the FBI because he
lies to a lot of people Michael tone
Michael coin once boasted that he would
take a bullet for Donald Trump but
instead this week he delivered a smoking
gun the fact that oh yeah that's the
smoking gun because it once again he
said that what I provided before was
consistent what the president wanted me
to say because I wanted to stay loyal to
the president
smoking guy saying he said essentially
that the the White House the president
was lying at the time that he had no
business dealing with Russia when he was
looking to strike a deal gay the
president has not testified the
president you know did say that he had
nodes business ties with Russia again
it's gonna come down to what is the
meaning of is Right the president's
gonna say I didn't have business ties
with Russia right we were in
negotiations it didn't happen so that's
not me weiying
people I'm left gonna say well you know
you're implying that there were no at
anytime business ties with Russia and
there were in any case none of that is
criminal as Andrea Mitchell says and
this is leading a lot of folks on the
right to more and more rip into the
Mullen report Rudy Giuliani the
president's attorney on these matters he
says that Robert Mahler is acting
unethically that basically he's calling
together a bunch of people he says have
lied to him but there's been no
underlying crime so
at no point has anybody been actually
convicted or pled guilty to collusion
with Russia regarding the election which
was the original charge instead
everybody's being gotten on ancillary
crimes of lying to the FBI about matters
that really have nothing to do with the
central contention that's what Giuliani
is saying he's not wrong I think the
special prosecutor has stepped over the
line now with the way he's intimidating
people in order to tell what he believes
is his version of the truth and this is
what's wrong with these special
prosecutors and independent counsels
they think they're God I mean they think
they know they know the only truth that
exists even if there's a lot of doubt
about it they seem to want to people at
any cost including the cost of ethical
behavior or the rights of people he's a
really Giuliani obviously quite upset
about all this so his president from
President Trump tweeted out this morning
a series of tweet says Michael Cohen s
judge for no prison time you mean he can
do all the terrible unrelated to Trump
things having to do with fraud big loans
taxis etc and not serve a long prison
term he makes up stories to get it great
and already reduced deal for himself and
get his wife and father-in-law who has
the money off scot-free I do like that
he spelled scot-free capital S co titi
free so there's a dude named Scott free
he lied for this outcome and showed in
my opinion serve a full and complete
sentence
I will never testify against Trump this
statement was recently made by Roger
stone essentially stating he will not be
forced by rogue and out-of-control
prosecutor to make up lies and stories
about President Trump nice to know that
some people still have quote-unquote
guts by Muller who's a much different
man than people think and his out of
control band of angry Democrats don't
want the truth they only want lies the
truth is very bad for their mission it
so in a second I'm going to say why I
think the president from sort of half
right and why he's sort of half wrong
but first let's talk about how you can
make your business better well the way
that you can make your business better
is by having better employees let's face
it half the people who work for you
slobs you need to replace them with
people who are not schlubs and this
means you need to go over to zip
recruiter calm right now hiring can be
pretty time-consuming you post a job to
several online job boards and the job
boards and they get tons of the wrong
resumes then you have to sort through
all the resumes to find a few people
with the right skills and experience job
sites that overwhelm you with the wrong
resumes those are not smart so
instead do the smart thing go to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire unlike
other job sites if quarter finds
qualified candidates for you it's
powerful mastering technology scans
thousands of resumes to identify people
with the right skills education and
experience and actively invites them to
apply to your job so you get qualified
candidates fast it is no wonder that zip
recruiter is rated number one by
employers in the United States this
rating comes from hiring sites on trust
pilot with over a thousand reviews right
now my listeners can try zip recruiter
for free at this exclusive web address
zip recruiter dot-com slash daily wire
if you love the show show your support
of it and zip recruiter by going to zip
recruiter comm slash daily wire we use
it here at the daily by our zip record
comm slash daily wear a zipper critter
is indeed the smartest way to hire no
reason for you to suffer with a bad
business check it out right now zip
recruiter comm slash it daily wire so
president Trump obviously upset with the
Muller investigation why because the
theory is that Muller is basically
getting a bunch of people to cop to
things that are not major crimes in
order to get them to flip on the
President and say things that are untrue
now a couple of things can be true at
once one can be that there is no
underlying crime here two can be that
the molar report is actually just a
report and not a criminal indictment
that it turns out that what Muller is
actually attempting to do is compile a
bunch of means stuff about Trump without
any sort of criminal indictment in the
offing and thing number three can also
be true which is that Muller in order to
get that information is going after
people for relatively minor crimes lying
to the FBI is not a minor crime but
about issues that are not exactly
criminal it's not exactly a major crime
either the person making this case is of
course Andrew McCarthy over at National
Review and it is important to note
before we start into McCarthy's case
that the that Muller is not allowed to
suborn perjury himself so if Muller were
to get Cohen's who lie about Trump if he
knew that Cohen were lying about
something and he said listen I'm gonna
prosecute you and put you in jail unless
you lie about Trump that is in and of
itself a crime so Muller is not doing
that but it is also true that it is
possible Cohen is going to testify about
a lot of stuff that's not actually
criminal it just makes from look bad and
that's McCarthy's take on all of this he
says no prosecutor builds a case the way
Muller is going about it
what prosecutor says here's our witness
lineup Michael Flynn George papadopolis
Alex vanderzwaan
Rick gates poem anaphor michael cohen
and what is it they have
common ladies and gentlemen bingo
they're all convicted Liars for a
prosecutor like any trial lawyer but the
jury thinks is at least as important as
what the law says if the most memorable
thing the jury takes into the
deliberation room is that no one should
believe a word your witnesses say you're
not going to convict the lowliest
grifter much less the President of the
United States instead what you have to
do is build your case by having your
cooperating accomplice witnesses plead
guilty to the big scheme you're trying
to pin on the main culprit they say
there was a big thing Trump was trying
to do I was a part of it now I'm
testifying about it but no one's
actually testifying to any of that stuff
he says in short you build a case by
first establishing the foundational
criminal offense juries do not convict
people because they like or trust the
prosecution's witnesses they convict
because they are persuaded that justice
demands redress for a real crime note
that word crime but there is no crime
here that is why from the beginning of
the Trump Russia investigation and
certainly since Muller's appointments on
May 17th 2017 we have stressed that the
probe is a counterintelligence
investigation not a criminal
investigation Muller does not have a
crime he is investigating he is
investigating in hopes of finding a
crime which is a day-and-night
different thing say here's what here's
what McCarthy concludes I think
correctly says that brings us to be
where there's smoke there must be fire
talking point Muller fans have been
trying out if all these people are lying
to cover up something that something
must involve some egregious criminality
that's ridiculous we know from our own
daily lives the crimes account for only
a very small percentage of the things
people lie about indeed throughout the
1990s Democrats insisted that
prosecutors should leave Bill Clinton
alone because everybody lies about sex
people lie about things they are
embarrassed or ashamed of politics is a
seeming business but politics is not a
crime consequently if you criminalize
politics if you turn a prosecutor lose
to invest investigate political campaign
activities you are apt to find unsavory
conduct that is not criminal but that
some people will lie about so why
exactly is Muller turning lies into
guilty pleas first he's not going to
indict the president so Muller is not
worried about the lack of credibility of
these witnesses second he knows the
media is going to cheer everything that
he does the media reports Muller is
investigating the Trump Russia collusion
dozens of people have been charged or
convicted but they will not report that
no one has been charged must less
convicted of any crime involving
collusion between Trump and Russia and
third defendants convicted of making
false statements are you
full because Muller is writing a report
not preparing for a jury trial convicted
liars never get cross-examined in a
report nor do they give the bumpy and
consistent testimony you hear in a
courtroom so this is really so Muller is
just putting together a report he's not
actually putting together a criminal
indictment and that means that he is
cobbling together all of these various
guilty pleas on lies that have nothing
to do with the main topic to get these
people to spill the beans about a non
criminal scheme that embarrasses Trump
and that's Trump's main case here and
that's the case you're going to see
Trump's legal team make none of this is
impeachable some of it may be
embarrassing but what is Robert Muller
doing here and Robert Mulder's case is
going to be listen when people lie to
the FBI that's a crime and it is my job
to prosecute people who commit crimes
this means that the real change for the
president Trump is in legally speaking
is of suborning perjury if Trump told
Michael Cohen or anybody else and they
ought to lie to the FBI that would be
the only criminality that I think Muller
is going to uncover here maybe I'm wrong
maybe there is an underlying crime and
after all this time after two years
Moana comes forward with the big reveal
and the big reveal is that Trump and
Putin were in the back room
hacking Hillary Clinton's emails
together like Matthew Broderick and
wargames maybe that's what was happening
but absent that big reveal all that's
happening here is Trump is turning all
the people around Trump into criminals
in order to get them to testify to
material that is non criminal but very
damaging to President Trump going into
2020 and that's why I team Trump is so
upset and that's why President Trump is
so upset and I think at least part of
that seems to be justified now I'm
waiting to I'm gonna wait until the
moment report comes out to say whether I
think that this is terrible or dishonest
and again two things can be true at once
one Muller can be honest mellon can be
doing his job and that job had no
boundaries from the outset and that lack
of boundaries has led a special
prosecutor to do what special
prosecutors always do which is find an
ancillary crime again Bill Clinton was
not impeached for committing an
underlying crime he's not impeached for
committing sexual assault against Paula
Jones he was impeached for committing
perjury he was impeached because he
suborned perjury President Trump could
get caught in the same trap here simply
by dint of the underlying crime so we'll
see how all of this plays out now
meanwhile we'd be remiss if we did not
talk about the situation in France
because right now France is basically on
fire the footage from
France is absolutely astonishing here is
some footage of the police firing rubber
bullets into crowds over by the arc de
triomph
in people marching down the centre of
Paris and the police who you will see in
black hair behind the barricades firing
rubber bullets into the crowd of people
who are wearing yellow it's pretty
amazing stuff and so the I mean
full-scale rioting in the streets of
France you can say I mean this is it's
legitimately like a pitched street
battle people throwing rocks at each
other the police officers who are
ducking behind their shields and then
firing rubber bullets into the crowd the
destruction is pretty astonishing as
well we have some of the pictures of the
destruction here's what some of the
destruction looks like not just the
smelling the streets people burning cars
in the streets people being water hosed
in the streets pretty amazing people who
are graffitiing all over the historic
sites in France people broke into the
museum gift shop over at the Louvre I
believe people overturning stuff in the
streets people destroying some of the
historic artifacts and statues from the
first French Republic and in the Arc de
Triomphe pretty incredible stuff so what
are all of these riots about it turns
out that reality has its day reality
suggests that people are going to riot
when they feel economically dispossessed
and they feel economically dispossessed
when you decide to tax them
extraordinary amounts of money to pay
for your global warming agenda that's
really what's happening in France right
now I'm going to talk more about that in
just one second at first it's
uncomfortable in France but you don't
have to be comfortable down below that's
why you need the best underwear on the
market dudes this holiday season as you
rack your brain for the perfect gifts I
have some tips for treating yourself and
everyone else on your list a
mind-blowing comfort its Tommy John the
revolutionary clothing company that is
redefining comfort Tommy John has the
most comfortable underwear for everyone
on the planet you can count on their
products to be snug and neat and to stay
in one place all of their underwear
supports a no edgey guarantee
comfortable stay put waist bands a range
of fabrics that are luxuriously soft
feather-light moisture wicking
breathable designed to move with you not
against you that means no bunching no
rolling no riding up so if you're still
on the fence wondering if Tommy trying
to be a memorable gift just think of the
fact that you're not going to be have to
be picking that wedgie or watching any
other friends do the same and with
limited edition holiday gifts and daily
deals there's something
for everyone on your list naughty or
nice give the gift of mind-blowing
comfort this holiday season with limited
edition holiday gifts from Tommy John
save 20% on your first order and Tommy
John comm / Ben that's Tommy John comm /
Ben again these underwear really are
terrific I'm wearing them right now and
let me say my level of comfort
extraordinary so good so good and also
whenever you throw Tommy John in the
washer you get cheaper pairs of
underwear and throw in the wash they
come out and the elastic is shot and
they're now sagging on you that's not to
do with Tommy John these things fit like
a glove the first time and they fit like
a glove after you've thrown them and
wash a bunch of times
durable excellent and they supported no
wedgie guarantee which as I say would
have helped me a lot in high school
Tommy John comm / Ben for 20% off Tommy
John comm / Ben go check it out right
now also before we go any further and I
have a lot more to get to on today's
show trade policy and the New York Times
ripping on Chanukah because what would a
day be in the New York Times without a
bit of anti-semitism or self-hating
jewelry we'll get to all that in just a
second but first you have to go over to
daily wire.com and subscribe tonight if
you're a subscriber you will
particularly enjoy our next episode of
daily Wired backstage holiday dish and
that's right I'm sacrificing my evening
once again to be here with you so if
you're not here I will take it as a sign
of personal ingratitude Tila where
god-king Jeremy boring me Andrew Klavan
the awful Michael Knowles and Alicia
Kratz will be here to talk holidays
politics and culture and of course
answered your questions as always only
daily where subscribers get to ask the
questions so make sure to subscribe
today coming up in 2019 I have to
announce this the Ben Shapiro radio show
will be extended to 3 hours is what you
get when you subscribe the Ben Shapiro
radio show is adding two full hours per
day so you got my podcast you already
get that and if you're a subscriber you
get that live all the way through but we
have two more hours per day with all the
great content you come to enjoy unless
you listen live on radio the only way
that you're gonna be able to actually
see all of that is to subscribe because
then you can watch it on demand you can
watch the full three hour show so make
sure to sign up for your subscription
today there's a hell of a pitch if
you're gonna sign up for the holidays I
am now expending three times the effort
to make sure that you enjoy your
subscription it's gonna be amazing
ok $9.99 a month gets you that also for
$99 a year you get this the very
greatest and beverage vessel so you get
all of that you can sit there in the
comfort of your own home as I sweat
bullets trying to bring you the
I am content three hours a day sipping
from this the leftist here's hot or cold
tumblr enjoying your life to the fullest
extent possible you will love it you
will live it it's spectacular and you
get all of those things for a
ninety-nine dollars a year which is a
solid deal I mean come on it's not gonna
get better than that also you get to be
part of our mailbag we have all sorts of
new benefits coming behind the paywall
that we are working on as I speak I'm
working on them in my head right now so
you get to go check that out right now
also check us out on YouTube or iTunes
we had a great Sunday special this week
with Pastor John MacArthur we have big
Sunday specials coming up in the near
future with a lot of very famous and
great thinkers as we do every Sunday you
get all access to all of these things go
subscribe to YouTube or iTunes and when
you do then you get the rest of the show
as well it comes in to your mailbox all
the good stuff go check it out leave a
sort of view we always appreciate it we
are the largest fastest-growing
conservative podcast in the nation
so over in France Emmanuel macron who
was the newly elected French prime
minister who defeated marine lepen in a
runoff that was hotly contested he is
wildly unpopular his popularity rings
her not like twenty six percent so the
press loves him people of France not so
much now this is breaking out into riots
according to the UK Daily Mail graffiti
was removed from the arc de triumphe
today after anti McCrone protesters
stormed through Paris on Saturday the
protesters occupied the city centre they
torched cars smashed windows with clubs
and axes stolen assault rifle from riot
police firing tear gas and water cannon
in france's worst urban rioting in years
the French president today vowed to
bring the rioters to justice as he is
inspected wreckage on the champs-elysees
the yellow vest protesters which began
as a rebellion against a fuel tax hike
but have expanded into weeks of civil
unrest today there's a massive strike of
ambulance employees which is I'm sure
great for folks who need to get to the
hospital and spread across the country
on Saturday ended with 133 people
injured including 23 police officers and
412 arrested last night on correct
myself by the way McCrone is the
president of France not the Prime
Minister two separate offices McCrone
was jarred by lingering yellow vests
supporters before chairing a crisis
meeting with ministers amid calls to
declare a state of emergency or even
send in the army to quell the violence
so why exactly are people protesting
because gas prices in France are out of
control and 60% of those gas prices are
giul to fuel taxes those fuel taxes are
largely created to pay for the crackdown
in global warming now is the earth
cooling specifically faster because of
all this no evidence of that but it's
short hitting the pocketbooks of a bunch
of people in France this is why when
folks on the Left say listen there's no
cost to good carbon policy there's no
cost to raising the carbon tax it's
going to create jobs everyone will be
happier mm-hmm yep going great and
France didn't it so McCrone held talks
with his prime minister and interior
minister at the Elysee Palace nearby
images showed the inside of the arc de
triumphe ransacked with the statue of
Marianne a symbol of the French Republic
smashed and graffiti sprawled scrawled
on the exterior the French leader spoke
with police and firefighters on one of
the avenues near the shops Elysee with
some yellowjacket and protesters
shouting McCrone resign the government
spokesman said it was out of the
question
each weekend becomes a meeting or ritual
for violence because this was the second
consecutive Saturday ending in violent
carnage in Paris the capital is calm on
Sunday but a motorway was blocked by
yellow vested and protesters in Lyon so
things are breaking down and they are
breaking down because it turns out that
when he wants you pay for socialistic
programs then people get angry this is
why when everybody's look all the people
in Europe they're so happy everything is
so great - spend some time over in these
places and see what the civil unrest
looks like in places like France before
you talk about radically raising the
taxes on American citizens to pay for
carbon emissions for example protesters
said the riots yesterday were the start
of a revolution in violence which echoed
the near revolution of 1968 Frederick
Lagash of the Alliance police union he
called for a state of emergency he said
we're in an insurrectional climate well
gosh that army reinforcements should be
brought in to guard public monuments
freeing up the police to deal with other
trouble spots and so things have gotten
very ugly over in France there are
consequences to public policy euronews
has a pretty good summary of what
exactly is happening in France they say
discontent was triggered by the
government's measures to keep increasing
a direct tax on diesel a fuel commonly
used by motorists in France as well as
the carbon tax protesters see these is
disproportionately affecting those who
use their cars to get to and from their
jobs every day their core demands are to
put a freeze on fuel tax increases due
in January and measures to boost
spending power the hike in fuel prices
is due to three things according to
euronews volatile crude oil prices the
carbon tax and diesel and petrol taxes
and the taxes are used to help finance
the general budget of the state so it is
not just that they argues for carbon
taxation they're also used to pay for
the exorbitant social system in France
France has serious problems not all the
rights in France over the past few years
have come in part from radical Muslim
immigrants you've seen riots in France
that have been disproportionately from
those folks in particular areas of the
country and you've also seen from the
right in France which is very upset with
the taxation policy in France civil
unrest tends to follow giant government
and this is what's happening in France
because again you can't have these
policies without some consequences
accompanying them if policies have
consequences sort of the theme of
today's show
at least in part and that is why
president Trump is now backing off
tariffs on the Chinese because President
Trump is looking at the economy and
starting to realize the tariff policy
undercuts everything that he is
currently trying to do in an
announcement yesterday Chinese President
Xi Jinping and President Donald Trump
put their bilateral trade war on pause
momentarily striking an agreement to
hold off on slapping additional tariffs
on each other's goods after January 1st
as talks continue between both countries
President Trump decided this was a big
win for him even though the reality is
that if Trump had and threatened tariffs
in the first place we wouldn't be
lowering tariffs in the second place
president Trump created a lot of trade
chaos and then when the trade cast is
temporarily postponed the stock market
jumped which is exactly what you're
seeing today in a White House readout of
a dinner at the g20 summit in Argentina
she and Trump discussed a range of
nettlesome issues among them the trade
dispute that is left over 200 billion
dollars worth of goods hanging in the
balance the statement read President
Trump has agreed then on January 1st
2019 he will leave the tariffs on 200
billion dollars worth of product at the
10 percent rate and not raised it to 25
percent at this time American and
Chinese officials will continue over the
next three months to negotiate lingering
disagreements on technology transfer
intellectual property and agriculture
meanwhile China will agree to purchase a
not yet agreed upon but very substantial
amount of agricultural energy industrial
and other products from the United
States reduce the trade imbalance
between our two countries China has
agreed to start purchasing agricultural
products from our farmers immediately it
sounds like a win for us except for the
fact that they were already purchasing
an enormous amounts of Agriculture from
us before right they were purchasing
basically our entire soybean supply for
example and it turns out that president
Trump's tariff policies rather than
lowering the trade deficit actually
increased that trade deficit an
expectation of the tariffs according to
Bloomberg the US trade deficit widened
in July by the most in three years the
gap with China hit a record as the Trump
administration imposed tariffs on a
range of Chinese goods prompting
retaliatory levies from Beijing turns
out that trade policy is all fun and
games until the actual consequences of
the trade policy become known I'm glad
the president is backing off of all of
this it is one thing to crack down on
the Chinese for fraud and intellectual
property infringement it's another thing
to impose tariffs just because President
Trump thinks he's protecting domestic
industry he is not in fact protecting
the domestic economy by taxing American
citizens for cheaper
from abroad okay meanwhile Alexandria
Ocasio Cortez has gotten herself in the
headlines again this time by tweeting
something insanely stupid again now I
know according to the media we're not
supposed to cover Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez right this is the way this works
is that the media say that the new
congresswoman from New York is a godsend
she's a fresh-faced she's wonderful in
every way and then if we talk about her
in place like this is oh you're obsessed
with her oh you're obsessed with her hey
this is just high-level media troller II
if you decide to make her celebrity and
then we talked about the fact that she
can't legitimately add numbers together
like basic numbers together then it's
our fault and then it's our fault how
dare we you make her a celebrity but if
we comment oh we're obsessed we're
obsessed listen she's a public figure
when she tweets something dumb then she
should be called out for it this is a
tweet that has 66 thousand likes here is
what she tweeted 21 trillion dollars of
Pentagon financial transactions could
not be traced documented or explained 21
trillion dollars in Pentagon accounting
errors Medicare for all cost 32 trillion
dollars that means 66 percent of
Medicare for all could have been funded
already by the Pentagon and that's
before our premiums okay this is
mathematically illiterate illiterate
okay the reason it is mathematically
illiterate is that we have not actually
spent 21 trillion dollars in the entire
history of the Republic of the United
States on defense okay we spent 700
billion dollars in total
last year she also claimed at one point
I believe that we had 700 billion
dollars in fraud that same year
okay this number does not add up that is
not a correct interpretation of the
numbers that she is looking at also
acknowledging that your program is
massively expensive to own the cons big
win for alexandra Ocasio course husband
oh sorry I'm not supposed to point out
when she says something really dumb
because that means that we are obsessed
with her here we're supposed to just
pretend that none of this is that none
of this is is happening so good stuff
from Alexandria Ocasio Cortes meanwhile
in other things stupid the New York
Times has a piece today about the
Rockettes
okay the Rockettes are too white is
according to jinnia Belafonte now if you
think that folks at the New York Times
are racist obsessed you would be correct
because everyone at the New York Times
has lost their minds here's what they
write over at the New York Times Ginny a
Belafonte November 30
she says on Wednesday as it happened I
went to see the Christmas Spectacular
starting the Radio City Rockettes which
is something you can do at 11 o'clock in
the morning in late November in
Manhattan I was by myself my son like so
many children growing up in New York and
fed with its imperious cultural
attitudes would sooner eat ahead of
escarole then choose to see something
dependent on the word spectacular is a
noun there are plenty of children in the
audience though even if it was a school
day plenty of old people in middle aged
people many of them were wearing Santa
hats the crowd was overwhelmingly white
this means that it's a bad show if a
crowd is overwhelmingly white it must be
bad if the crowd at the at the latest
Beethoven concert is overwhelmingly
white that means Beethoven is bad I
mentioned this fact because at the end
of the second decade of the 21st century
the Rockettes whose performances are
taken in by almost 1 million people
every holiday season are themselves
almost all white so not all white almost
all white it's not enough that they have
some non-white members of the cast it's
not diverse it's not diverse enough it
must be it's just like segregation the
show I saw featured as far as I could
tell only one african-american dancer in
the lineup of close to 40 there weren't
any and more camels on stage than black
women by the way if you go to a rack
cast show and your first inclination is
start counting the black women I'd say
you have a problem among the 80 dancers
who made up the Rockettes core 10
percents are women of color a
spokesperson for the company told me
you're only seeing half the cast during
any given show because there's so many
performances to fill on weekends up to 6
a day regardless of that any variance in
skin tone is obscured by lighting and
makeup that have the effect of creating
a stolt defying homogeneity they need a
New York Times columnist to tell them
how to run the Rockettes which has been
a continuous show on Broadway for
decades ancillary cast members in the
pageant non Rockettes include a black
man playing an elf and a black man
playing a Bell man oh no by the way
speaking of playing an elf my sister a
Jewish girl played an elf in her
elementary school public school
production of a Christmas thing I guess
that was also anti-semitic or something
there are cats are the creation of
someone named Russell markered who first
brought them to stage in st. Louis in
1925 oversaw their direction at the
Radio City Music Hall from the 30s until
the 70s his goal had been build to build
the most precise and uniform dancing
troupe in the world and to that end he
imposed height requirements for the
women in the line these expectations
have continued unabated
such a vision accommodates little
tolerance for difference I agree I think
that the Radio City Rockettes should be
forced to perform with people who are
paraplegic for
example I think that the Radio City rock
has half of them should be in
wheelchairs I think it wouldn't change
the nature of the show at all and would
show a massive understanding of the
diversity of modern America if that were
to happen we should have a bunch of
people who are short
we should have bunch of people who are
super tall they should dance to whatever
they wanted ants to actually there
shouldn't actually be any sort of
attempt to make them dance in line or in
lockstep that's fistic we should
actually just let them dance how they
wanna dance
if someone intends jazz that's cool if
some want to breakdance that's totally
fine as well if someone want to scoot
along on their butt for no reason at all
like my two and a half year old son I
think they should do that - because
that's diversity that's diversity and
all those people should be racially
diverse those people should be diverse
in terms of sexual orientation they
should be diverse in terms of gender
identification I don't see why the Radio
City Rockettes can't be a bunch of
mustachioed men I don't think like all
of this I think is is just on American
so thank you New York Times for really
hitting in on the spirit of the holiday
really honing in on what makes the Radio
City Rockettes run the way they're
supposed to run okay time for some
things that I like and then some things
that I hate so things that I like as we
watch France burst into flame and as we
recognize that America still is the
greatest Democratic Republic in the
history of the planet despite all of the
problems that we experienced it is worth
reviewing why that is the book that best
describes this is democracy in America
by Alexis de Tocqueville I know you're
recommended this in high school then you
didn't read it and then you were
recommended in college and then you
recommended in grad school and you still
didn't read it
well now I'm recommending it and you
should read it okay this edition is
particularly good it's an Edition that
is edited by Harvey Mansfield the
brilliant professor over at Harvard east
coast Straus Kiev as well as double
Winthrop it is it is a very very good
edition and the translation is is
excellent it is well edited the
introduction is really good Alexis de
Tocqueville describes well what makes
democracy and America different from
democracy in other nations he talks
about localism he talked about the
prevalence of a social fabric he talks
about the fact that a Democratic
Republic is not quite a democracy and
not quite a republic and he talks about
the the foolish idea that the people
will always be a cure and then the main
message of Alexis de Tocqueville is
democracy in America in a nutshell is
that democracy in America can only work
if there's a vibrant social fabric that
supports the democracy and the system of
checks and balances
does
to facilitate democracy not only checks
the excesses of the people but in the
end does in fact rely on a good and
moral people it's a long book it'll take
you a long time to complete but once you
do you'll have a better understanding of
what makes America tick and why for
example the French Republic has not
worked in nearly the same way as the
American Republican okay other things
that I like so speaking of books that
everyone should read yesterday and went
to Barnes & Noble with my kids because
this is one of the things we like to do
my daughter who is a very smart human
for her age I always always had for her
age because whenever I say a child is
smart people like well you should let
her decide her own gender as like no
that's not no she's smart for a 4 and a
half year old which means she can read
in any case there's a book on the shelf
let me first note over at Barnes & Noble
the children's section is basically a
propaganda tool I say that's only
because I walk in and the first display
you see is feminism for babies there's
literally a book called baby feminism
and what it is a picture of like Ruth
Bader Ginsburg and then it's a board
book you know it's made out of the thick
cardboard so if your kids chew on it it
doesn't ruin the book and it's a picture
of Ruth Bader Ginsberg and if you flip
it if you flip the page it's then a
picture of Ruth Bader Ginsburg as a baby
because every feminist was once a baby
and now it doesn't actually have the
punchline which is if feminists had
their way many of these babies would
never been born but nonetheless that is
one of the books on the shelf also a
Michelle Obama biography is on the shelf
is a bunch of left-leaning books my
favorite though was this one my mom
actually spotted this one and let it be
known that just as my wife is a doctor
my mom runs companies okay she's a
business if she ran business affairs for
major television and film companies in
Los Angeles for years so my mom actually
worked outside the house and my dad was
home with the kids my mom is a
first-rate first wave feminist in any
case she spots this book and I see her
sit down and start reading it and she
just starts laughing the title of the
book is my first book of feminism for
boys and it is just incredible it is
just the best so she hands it to me to
read and I will say this book is so
informative and so great it's by Julie
Marburg illustrated by Michelle Broome
irreverent the best page is a picture of
a girl and a firefighters uniform who is
lugging a hose because she wants to be a
firefighter which is fine although I
will say that female upper body strength
is not as great as
upper-body strength on average and if
you just had to pick a guy to be a
firefighter or a girl to be a
firefighter no nothing else about them
you have to pick the guy because
obviously the at you have to go by the
average the average is the men have more
upper body strength also I do love the
accuracy of one woman carrying a fire
hose which generates like a thousand
pounds of pressure and requires at least
two or three guys to carry in any case
here is but I'm not gonna rip on the
accuracy of a children's book it's just
a children's book but here's the caption
find a job that you love heading off to
each day know the women you work with
must earn equal pay you're supposed to
read this like two and a half year old
so I sat there and I read it to my two
and a half year old and he looked at me
very solemnly and he said this claim
does not adjust for job choice time out
of the workforce or hours work and I
said my boy you are just you you have
been well put on your way sir and that
was and that was our actual conversation
word for word it was really incredible I
mean I didn't know that he knew about
adjustments for job choice I didn't know
he knew about statistical regressions
and and multiple regression linear
analysis I didn't know he knew about all
that stuff it turns out not only did he
know all this stuff I let him drive home
it was really amazing so check out that
book my first book of feminism for boys
I'm buying it for my business partner as
his Christmas gift because I think he
needs to know more about feminism so he
should go check that ok final final
thing that I like today so over the
weekend so first of all you should go
check out on Friday I did a 2-hour
conversation with Jordan Peterson and
Dave Rubin all about Christianity and
Judaism and religion and meaning and
purpose it's really good stuff it's
really fun
Jordan and I are good friends at this
point there's a lot to tell then - I
think that it's really worthwhile and
then Jordan and Dave suggested that I
stopped by Jordan's show which was
fantastic it did a show at the LA
Orpheum over the weekend a couple
thousand people and I got to come out
and I got to say hello and and as a
gesture of solidarity I brought Dave
Rubin a cupcake the reason being last
time I was on Dave's show he asked me
whether I would make a cake for his
same-sex wedding and I said no because
I'm a religious person and I do not
participate in ceremonies that I think
are a sin even though we are friends
right and this is true with regard to
intermarriage this is true with regard
to Sabbath violation I mean this is true
for a wide variety of things that as a
religious person i consider sinful now
they've can do what he likes right I
mean he's married
guy right me he can do what he wants
it's a free country and that's fine I'm
good friends with Dave and friends with
his with his husband and all that's fine
but I is a religious person I'm not
going to be compelled by a government or
anyone else to violate my religious
scruples and celebrate something that I
believe is personally a a sin okay
that's my perspective I said that people
went nuts so to prove that Dave and I
are friends and that also I have no
objection to actually baking a cupcake
for a gay guy I baked him a cupcake I
brought it to him on stage and and I
pointed out that I'm happy to make a
small cake for a gay man so that is the
thing that happened over the weekend and
then I also pointed out that I had in
fact brought a cake for Jordan Peterson
backstage as well but it wasn't a
physical cake it was a mythological cake
it had lots of layers and it's the
layers that made it so bloody important
you see I would anyone bring him an
actual physical cake a physical cake
connotes sweetness and life isn't sweet
life is pain and suffering in which your
journey is to make order out of chaos
and that's what you're supposed to learn
from the metaphysical mythological cake
that has been bubbling up in our
biologies and from a deeper place for
legitimately hundreds of thousands of
years once we understand the suffering
of the mythological cake then you
understand the sweetness which is far
sweeter than any physical cake could be
in the hierarchy and that's that's why
it's so bloody important in any case it
was really a lot of fun and I love
Jordan Jordan's great so it's
unfortunately not on tape but that's my
best recreation of what I actually said
on stage at the at the event at the LA
Orpheum you should go if you if Jordans
in your town you should go see his
events they're really really cool and
really a lot of fun okay time for a
couple of things that I hate okay so
this weekend began the holiday of
Hanukkah Hanukkah is a great holiday
Hanukkah is also an anti secularist
holiday so Hanukkah is all about the
Jews defeating the Helenus a group of
members of the Seleucid Empire who are
attempting to take over the Jewish
temple transform it into a pagan temple
and a lot of Jews who are going along
with this because better to assimilate
than to be part of the Jewish people the
Maccabees rise up in a religious revolt
and they say no we are taking back our
holy places and we refuse to bow before
the hellenization of our religion this
is very uncomfortable for a lot of
people it's particularly uncomfortable
for secular Jews who don't actually care
all that much about Judaism and for whom
Chanukah is largely a reverse Christmas
it's basically a Christmas for our kids
so we're uncomfortable with having a
Christmas tree in our house because we
don't believe in the Jesus but by the
same token it's let's get kid gifts for
our kids we have to have like Hanukkah
Harry and we'll have like a Hanukkah
bush and all this kind of stuff okay
that is precisely the opposite this is
precisely the opposite of what actually
has been the the history of celebrating
the holiday now what's hilarious about
this is that there was a secular Jew in
the newer times who recognized the
hypocrisy his own hypocrisy and this his
name is Michael David loukas and he says
it's the question that Jewish parents
instinctively dread a few months ago I
was sitting on the couch with my
three-year-old daughter watching youtube
videos about animals in space when out
of nowhere she looked up at me and asked
data can we celebrate Christmas we don't
celebrate Christmas I told her putting
on my serious voice we celebrate
Hanukkah like generations of Jewish
parents performing I did my best to sell
her on the relative merits of Hanukkah
true Christmas might have sparkly trees
ornaments and fruitcake
but we have latkes jelly doughnuts an
eight and eight nights of presents so we
have Santa's chests hopefully no I said
and her face dropped they do I tried to
reiterate the part about jelly doughnuts
in the eight nights of presents but she
wasn't having any of it I can't say I
blame her during the rest of the year
the Jewish holidays we celebrate her
like special bonus celebrations we get
to have on top of everything else going
on in the calendar with Hanukkah and
Christmas however it's a zero-sum game
most of the yard isn't hard for our
family to feel both American and Jewish
but in December that dual identity
becomes more of a question which is why
Hanukkah is a big deal for mostly
assimilated Jews like myself the only
trouble is the actual holiday not the
latkes and dreidels but the story of
Hanukkah which at its heart is an eight
night long celebration of religious
fundamentalism and violence I like that
they just
discovered that the preservation of the
Jewish people is based on you know
Judaism and also on the preservation of
Judaism it's amazing so watching secular
Jews discover that Chanukah isn't
actually just reverse Christmas is
really amusing to me for people who
actually live the Jewish lifestyle and
take the Bible seriously and take
Judaism seriously and allow Judaism to
really permeate their lives Chanukah is
just another celebration of the fact
that Judaism is a deep-rooted part of
our life that will not allow
encroachment by hellenizing forces for a
bunch of secular Jews who basically been
Hellenized they suddenly realize oh wait
we're celebrating something we totally
disagree with real weird he says for
most of the past 2,000 years
Chanukah was an afterthought on the
Jewish calendar a wintertime festival of
lights during which people spun tops and
a greasy food to commemorate what has to
be one of God's least impressive
miracles a small container of oil lasted
for eight nights yeah that isn't there's
a big argument in even the Talmud about
what exactly is being celebrated whether
what's being celebrated is the the oil
or whether what's actually being
celebrated is the victory of the Jews
over the Seleucid Empire suffice it to
say I think it's the latter more
recently as Jews have become assimilated
into American society the holiday has
evolved into a kind of Semitic sidekick
for Christmas and then he talks about
how uncomfortable he is he says the more
I thought about all this the more
disturbed me for what am i if not a
Hellenized Jew I eat pork every so often
before having children my wife and I
agonized over the question of
circumcision and while I've never
offered burn sacrifices to zoos I do go
to yoga occasionally when it comes down
to it it's pretty clear the Maccabees
would have hated me yeah yep fair they
would have hated me because I'm
assimilated and because I'm the product
of intermarriage well I'm not sure they
would have hated you per se but they
would not have liked if you were
speaking up on behalf of Judaism and
well I can't say for certain what the
Maccabees would have thought about my
fondness for Bernie Sanders or my
practice practice of Reconstructionist
Judaism I'm pretty sure they wouldn't
have liked those things either yes that
is correct and then he says so why
should I do all of this the answer
frankly is that it's not my choice with
my daughter ready to sign up for Team
Santa we have to celebrate something and
I'm not quite Hellenized enough to get a
Christmas tree and this is secular
judaism in a nutshell in the United
States secular Judaism in a nutshell is
I don't want to be known as a Christian
because it makes me culturally
uncomfortable but I don't actually give
a damn about Jewish things and Jewish
things make me uncomfortable so instead
I sort of keep the hallmarks with
out uncomfortably recognizing what it is
that Judaism has stood for for so long
when people ask me one of the big
questions I get why are Jews so liberal
the answer is many Jews are liberal
because they are this kind of Jew
they're a Jew who actually doesn't like
a lot of the central tenets of Judaism
and is Hellenized beyond all measure but
simply does not have the guts to simply
say goodbye to the religion as a whole
Judaism is not for the faint of heart
and Judaism does have central tenets
just like Christianity is not for the
faint of heart and it does have central
tenets and trying to secularize holidays
is a huge huge mistake your kids won't
be celebrated this guy's worried about
his kid he won't have to worry about his
kids and his grandkids will not be
celebrating Hanukkah anytime in the near
future as soon as they are adults
because people instinctively recognize
hypocrisy and by the way what's what's
what's sad about all of this is that all
the folks who think that secularizing
and Hollen izing is going to protect
them from anti-semitism good luck with
that historically speaking that has
certainly not been true which is why in
a new survey 43% of Dutch Jews hide
their Jewish identity okay so that's not
going to work for them either and Jews
are still going to be Jews already so we
will have a lot more to discuss but
we'll be back here tomorrow for all of
it I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben
Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018